So we have a working application now,
but
we should probably add some style to it,
if we want it to be appealing to users.
Flask can automatically look for
CSS, JavaScript, and media files,
if we put them in a folder named static.
So I will create a folder called static,
in the same directory as
my project.py file, as so.
I will create a CSS file, and
name it styles.css, and
store it inside of this directory.
By adding this following
link to my template files,
I will tell Flask to use this styles.css
file when it renders this template.
When I refresh my browser,
I turn my old unstyled menu page
into one that looks like this.
Take some time to add some
styles to your menu app.
My CSS file and templates can be found
in the instructor notes for reference.